[Music]
the xbox360 is 10 years old 10 years
gentlemen and Kahneman Lam I am also 10
just that you say no God Harry to you 10
I am 10 multiplied nice it's it's been a
good good long period of time to still
making games for it do you still have
came out on their titanfall Tomb Raider
this has kind of been the last year for
the Xbox 360 this is kind of when we've
seen the transition where we're not
getting more Xbox 360 ps3 games
everything is getting cancelled for that
in favor of Xbox one oppose now you've
got that whole backwards compatibility
so you're gonna be able to resell and
bundle all 360 games with every remake
and sequel I think that's really kicked
people in the nuts who are working on HD
like the casual crafts are Castle
Crashers HD they had no idea backwards
compatibility having yeah and they were
like it's like my meat boy just came out
on ps4 and everything inside like FIFA
for like years to come right I mean
they're always like the the last few
years are just like here's like 9 more
sports games like legacy edition or I
think even I want to say this year's
games might have been branded legacy
Edition oh maybe I'm Call of Duty did
the thing or they stripped out to
campaign as well Roger seems to be the
big Triple H games and then Sports ones
guys because they're not allowed to call
them shitty edition yeah campaign we're
not like you know it's fine but you know
a version without it you know I was
gonna play it for Game of the Year stuff
but you probably okay let's not talk
about the sort of the the the gray ears
of the console let's talk about it's
wonderful youthful of prime so what were
some of the best red ring in left and
right that you got pride yeah the early
days of 360 how many did you go through
how many three original three I only had
to die I had my first elite my launch
360 still works because I bought an
elite and stopped using it before the
break did you have any I had one I was
pretty lucky I think I have one red ring
which I managed to wrap the towel round
and sit back into temporary health until
it finally gave up the guys but no I
think I think I was pretty lucky cuz I
only went through one until I moved on
to an elite so I also only went through
one
in fact they fixed that one and send it
back to me but now because it's a pile
one and I moved over here and like none
of the games of work so I had to bring
it with me but it's like I had to take
off the face by yourself because the
disk drive is so broken that I can wedge
a knife in every time I take the disc
out so now it just looks like it's we
have a room out the back which is you
know filled with the the the caucuses of
the same spot repository of they don't
want the name or yeah we asked my crew
when I was at one of your getting rid of
these consoles like hey do you want to
take our old original Xbox ones and 360
no Xbox ones Xbox original lid no like
we do we have two red ring debugs over
there so it's just like and no one wants
those there anyway I'm not talking about
breaking hardware or old-ass FIFA games
coming out on old consoles and the best
games came out on xbox 360 when I say
that Jeff what's the first game two
pumps and it's burnout paradise bring me
on here did not talk about burnout
paradise like words can bottle them as
well
no it is not oh it's not it is something
that they said was coming but I don't
think was part of that initial wave so
unless they've added it past that
initial wave I don't believe it's there
yet in a weird way that game is doing
stuff now that did stuff then which
racing games now are basically hanging
there sort of coats on it's well yeah
yeah I think so and you know there was a
way I want to say it was it was the most
wanted not the not the original two
thousand five thousand six one but the
criteria yeah the criterion most wanted
was basically a burnout game in the way
in terms of the way it's multiplayer was
structured it's actually one of the sad
things about where Need for Speed has
been at this past couple years is like
it's just they they lost it they had it
and they lost it they had it all figured
out they nailed it mm-hm and then now
I've gotten so far away from nailing it
yeah that's it's a great driving game
well they own the rights to Burnett now
as well so yeah shall we see maybe a
resurgence it's the it's one of these
games that was super popular with
critics didn't sell it off to a bunch
load well yeah it's one of the things
where it's like just the virtue of
writing Need for Speed on the box makes
it some more copies then burn out right
just because it's a more established
brand
y-you know criterion took over a need
for speed and then they split off to do
ghost games and also there's like
there's burnout lineage all over Need
for Speed now it's just the wrong parts
of the lineage or making its way in now
but yeah I think that's a fantastic game
gosh I mean you know halos golden years
took place on the Xbox halo 3 you know
wonderful 3 was a terrific game reaches
a good game ODST is a lot of fun you
know like kind of the those were those
if I had to pick three Halo games those
are the three right you know gears I
think was pretty transformative this was
a huge one for me what drove with me I
was a PC gamer up to that point yeah and
or primarily a PC gamer and you know a
lot of my time it does a multiplayer
which drove along my game time was was
was was playing you know early Call of
Duty it was playing day of defeat you
know counter-strike in the office on a
land with friends and it was live which
changed live which brought me over to
console primarily and and Gears was a
big part of that on warfare was a big
part of that but it was primarily the
left 4 dead games I mean those games
when we when I joined GameSpot CNET back
in 2006 in the UK soon after that but
those were those were the years when
everyone in the office would get
together as a social gathering online on
Friday night and play left there was
like Gears was one of those as well like
event games where it seemed like
everyone was buying them so that they
could all play with it and I think you
know the social aspect of multiplayer
gaming was before that for me was driven
by physically being with people in an
office on a land when I played online I
played a fair bit online it would be
against randoms yeah all of a sudden
being able to bring your group of
friends together and play online make a
day when you all got home on Friday
night to get pizza in and a news live
that that transformed it for me at least
and I mean left 4 dead 1 and 2 those
games are pretty impeccable yeah unlike
sort of a crazy
I don't know showing off just how far
multiplayer games of common consoles
where you at a game like that for dead
which involves so much cooperation that
you know people had sort of gotten used
to playing with each other so much it
seems like that was better than than it
is now like I don't feel like the Xbox
one or ps4 like playing with parties
right
experiences yeah well yeah there are
near the great co-op experiences aren't
always happening and then I mean you
know the the party stuff on Xbox one
wasn't so mangled and still you know
they've they've made improvements but I
feel like it's not maybe not where it
needs to be and also I think you know
maybe we've changed or I think we've
changed to a certain extent we're like
you know I used to feel okay about
wearing a headset while just playing a
game you know with random people like
that like played a lot of Call of Duty
for like I was you know another huge
huge huge Xbox 360 game for me and was a
little more willing to just kind of even
just hear what people had to say wait I
don't want to hear yeah I do not wear a
headset unless I'm play the only time I
ever wear a headset now for for
multiplayer or any form of gaming is
when I'm in a private party with friends
I mean that's it I mean I don't play
with random ya know it's like you hear
voices coming out her TV it sounds you
know comedy there was like something
that was like super ubiquitous during
the Xbox eyes man yeah it was like now
it's like a nuisance you're saying what
is this idiot like he's not even he's
talking to someone else or like worse
nowadays they're running a live stream
yeah and they've left their chat on to
the game so you're listening to them
commentate their own game as they're
playing it yours like days of watching
guys doing cocaine while playing ooh no
that was that was maybe if I had to pick
one moment for Xbox Live it was the
night I tuned in and saw Xbox Live
vision cameras and like people just
straight up Canadians doing lines while
playing you need to tune into
PlayStation never know yeah there's some
weird stuff out is that still going
strong a few legacy song might not be
the right very very there's a business
section of society that storms with Xbox
Live I think changed things but it was
also the achievement points like that
was the only time in my life when I
cared about these and was working at one
up calm and egm and we had active
competitions to see who could get the
most achievement points and you're just
playing all these shitty games like
Avatar they're gonna be like how quickly
can I get a thousand points for this and
how many points did you guys get over
there see I was never as high issue like
shoot she was our de facto he was
dan shu editor-in-chief egm at the time
I got hit my mom about 40,000 now 46 but
I was up 40 I have two accounts so I
have 25 on my own account before I moved
to the US but at some point I dropped
off but that was actually what you're
gonna buy your digital dick though
whatever well mine is now 150 well I was
gonna say if you gonna speak to anyone
about treatments because I remember
watching this man okay so I was like we
ran the videos on the site about how do
ya NBA to case that era of GameSpot I
was like you know me and Carrie goose
goose and a few other people on staff
like were gotten super into that stuff
well yeah Carrie and I bought Japanese
360s so that we could buy Japanese games
to get points also and within school it
was like that we'd friends who I'd who
never owned the Microsoft console never
that didn't touch the original Xbox and
suddenly we were all just like going out
of it at achievements and like passing
get like in college or passing games
around being like oh you want this one
it's like an easy 1,000 yeah really old
anything but they still exist but I just
don't care it PlayStation introduced
trophies like okay oh yeah that stuff
came in too late you know you know if
you had to pick one number pretty early
on on that one and it was like okay
you're adding trophies midstream on the
ps3 like whatever and and now that you
know steam achievements have never met
anything and then yeah you know and then
ever hit reset on Xbox one so he never
felt like you wanted to get my garage
and also just that you know I think
things got muddied in terms of like
where the lead platform was and where
third parties were we're kind of putting
their efforts and stuff like that like
you know the Sony's of you know the the
market leader right now I think changes
a lot of price for that stuff as well so
yeah but for me it was just strictly
strictly like no one was interested in
keeping up anymore it was just like okay
well I'm done with this this is insane
why am I doing this why am i doing this
oh god why am I doing this no I Reiner
Andrew Reiner a Game Informer was his I
think he is higher than I am later yeah
well and part of it was like crazy it
was this thing that it introduced in the
games that made me want to dive into
them deeper it's like if it's a game
that I love I just want to get the most
out of it like Assassin's Creed 2 is I
think the last game that I did
absolutely everything maybe
maybe you know Bioshock was it was
before that but it's like oh I'm just
want to get all 1000 treatments
everything for the DLC yeah what's
everything that I can get out of this
game it was like proving to myself that
I have milked it for everything yeah it
was a super interesting like barometer
of how much of the game you did
completed outside of this sort of the
big triple-a stuff though also on the
xbox360 we saw the sort of rise of
independent development getting concept
well actually probably just across the
board like the real big rise of the
Indies but especially being able to play
indie games on consoles and games that
went on to sell millions Xbox Live
Arcade was just an amazing platform for
these really tiny games that I mean we
mentioned you know but braid and Castle
Crashers like bringing the behemoth to
prominence was was because of XBLA there
was I mean there's the summer of arcade
was it was a real highlight of every
year while that was running and I mean
one of my favorite games I'm on the
entire years of 360 is Shadow Complex
right I mean it's like still still
waiting for that sequel right but but
you know there were there were real
highlights that came through the live
program and that did change the
landscape because Sony was way behind on
that yeah for sure totally and then you
know it was one of those things that
like it seems insane now that they
limited it to like one game a week right
but nowadays you know it's like tons of
those games tons of download-only games
are coming out Tim ps4 and Xbox one and
like there's no fanfare just like stuff
just appears you're like oh is that I
didn't ever heard of just appears on my
station no market you know there's
there's no yeah it's just stuff just
shows up out of it I don't know where it
yes seemed special it's it they almost
felt like Triple A games just like but
like sort of cheaper a little like meat
when meat boy came around but everyone
was of waiting for Super Meat Boy to
come at that morning but then you know
there were definitely weeks were like
the game was awful and you're like man
this sucks that yeah but I'm more than
one game I think there was there was a
double edge to that and it's a little
bit behind the scenes but back then we
also had access to all of those games
for free like as things weren't
downloaded or as things were put onto
the system we had our debug units with
lettuce just download oh wow I played
leave them play these and try them out
which we don't have now with Xbox one
and ps4 but it was like a way to try
these out and see like well what's worth
it and just having immediate access to
everything other stuff before it came
that stuff was really spotty because
there were games that showed up there
that never shipped
yeah oh wow like someone was working on
an RBI
baseball years and years ago at one
point that showed up and was playable
and it was like okay is this ever gonna
get announced to come out turns out no
and never gotten officially announced it
came out like you know word of it kind
of got out you know there's supposed to
be an NDA in place to talk about stuff
that appears on partner I feel like
enough years of maybe past that it's
maybe okay now but but yeah like stuff
like that would happen there was that
Saints Row a downloadable game that was
like the guide the bullet thing that
showed up there I don't think that ever
came out yeah that stuff was what school
and then I guess in terms of the
increased power that we saw on those
consoles coming out of the previous
generation with the original Xbox and
PlayStation 2 you know just cause 3s and
next week and we saw the sort of the
rise of the open-world game where like
you know GTA 3 obviously done really
well on ps2 and had its own trilogy but
in the time the Xbox 360 was that we got
Grand Theft Auto 4 we got you know Red
Dead Redemption
well elder scrolls oblivion one of the
early games was I mean that was a real
it's funny we never obviously I know you
guys chatting about fallout last week in
terms of some of the the technical
issues with that game about at that time
elder scrolls oblivion was that was the
cutting edge and I remember seeing the
initial screens and then seeing well
that was doing running on on that new
console which was only a year in at the
time I said very early and it was it was
astonishing and it came out at a time
the people were starved for something
unique on that console you know so like
that came out people liked it okay you
know unless they played mortal wind on
them Xbox or something they'd never seen
anything like that
there were people buying that game who
would never touch a fantasy gaming yeah
I mean that game made obviously like
made Bethesda yeah you know it was in
the right place the right time and it
was it was a just a great great game and
it introduced this to microtransactions
with horse armor yeah so many great
first right
okay let's before we wrap this up if you
had to pick one we're coming into game
of the air territory which is the
horrible Sophie's Choice of trying to
figure out what the best game is and a
catalog of wonderful games so going down
to catch if you have to pick one game at
a text box 360 that would be your
favorite Jeff first of all worthy
oh man I I'm gonna probably stick with
with Brenna paradise for the 360 rock
band
probably one of the run of the rocking
runners probably comes close as well
yeah just my baby so it's probably the
coke but I guess you know that castle
like castle crashes I have so many fond
memories I'm just like sitting with
friends on the couch pool and just
plowing through that game like I loved
castle crashers thanks Ben
well best experience left it to just
form memories but probably the best game
Red Dead Redemption yeah I mean to me
that's still rockstars best game last
time we gave me gave me two years well
yes 20 all right was around the end of
the it was 20 console yeah man this game
people can't wait for a sequel yeah let
me tell you about bully though we're
gonna talk about it yes that's alright I
guess that actually that did come to 360
360 was John mu stranglehold anyways Oh
table tennis right was so crazy oh man
like that was though as someone who's
colorblind that game was a huge about it
was all about the color the bonus spin
on the ball was represented by a color
and they had no options for life sure my
wife would literally cut like that it's
so realistic this is the future of
gaming tango that's it this black room
with you yes we're looking at Axl's
gentleman thanks for coming on have been
Justin enjoy okay let us know what you
think of the xbox360
10 years later are you ready to pick one
up what's your favorite game that came
out during and how's the time I know
alright guys super cheap and there
probably won't break and if it does you
won't get a replacement yeah what's your
favorite game on the Xbox 360 let us
know in the comment box below
[Music]